INDIVIDUALS TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
AN ALREADY DIFFICULT SITUATION.
JULIO, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND THE MEDIA WANTS YOU TO
BELIEVE THAT JOE BIDEN IS A
CANDIDATE OF EMPATHY AND
COMPASSION.
JOE CARES.
BUT MY NEXT GUEST IS LIVING
PROOF THAT IS FALSE.
FORMER PROFESSIONAL BOXER
CHARLES DUKE TANNER WAS
SENTENCED TO 30 YEARS IN PRISON
ON FEDERAL DRUG CHARGES, BUT
UPON ENTERING PRISON, TANNER
SAYS HE IMMEDIATELY BEGAN
WORKING TO IMPROVE HIMSELF AND
ATONE FOR HIS CRIME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK NOTICE,
GRANTING MR. TANNER LENIENCY
LAST WEEK, SOMETHING PRESENT
OBAMA WAS DECLINED TO DO.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP, THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME A SECOND CHANCE.
I DIDN’T KNOW IT WAS REAL, THIS
LITTLE GUY RIGHT HERE, I LEFT
HIM TWO YEARS OLD AND YOU ARE
NIGHT AND ME BACK TO MY FAMILY.
I LEFT MY MOTHER AND MY FATHER,
BUT I GOT HIM, AND THIS IS WHAT
I LIVED FOR.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Laura: MOST OF US WHO WATCH
OUT FOR THE FIRST TIME WERE IN
TEARS, SECOND CHANCES.
DUKE TANNER JOINS ME NOW.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
HOW DID YOU FIND OUT THE
PRESIDENT WAS THE IMPETUS BEHIND
YOUR RELEASE?
>> I REALLY DIDN’T KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON, BECAUSE MY TEAM CAME
AND GOT ME AFTER THE 4:00 P.M.
COUNT, LIKE THEY NEEDED TO TALK
TO ME, AND HE SAID "I’VE GOT TO
GET YOU OUT OF HERE."
I SAID, "WHERE MY GOING?"
SAID, "THE PRESIDENT GRANTED YOU
CLEMENCY.
I JUST STARTED PRAISING GOD.
THE NEXT THING I KNOW, I WAS AT
A HOTEL AND GOING TO THE
AIRPORT.
>> Laura: AND YOUR SON, YOUR
MOMENT WITH YOUR SON IN THAT
VIDEO, IT JUST HIT ME IN THE
HEART, AS A MOM.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE, SEEING HIM
AND REALLY SPENDING TIME WITH
HIM WITHOUT OTHER PEOPLE
WATCHING?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT SITUATION WITH
MY FAITH AND MY BELIEF AND MY
LORD AND SAVIOR JESUS CHRIST I
GOT A FREE GIFT FROM HIM, HIS
SECOND BEST GIFT IN LIFE WAS
GIVING TO ME BY
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP, THAT DAY
WHEN I WAS ABLE TO BE IN MY
SON’S LIFE AND REUNITE WITH HIM,
SOMETHING -- I WAS GIVEN A LIFE
SENTENCE, A DOUBLE LIFE
SENTENCE, THAT WAS REDUCED TO 30
YEARS.
THAT DAY RIGHT HERE IS THE
SECOND BEST THING BESIDES
GETTING MY SALVATION, BEING FREE
AND BEING IN MY SON’S LIFE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY
SOMETHING FOR YOU, DUKE, THAT
JOE BIDEN SET OF ALL
PRESIDENT TRUMP DURING THAT LAST
DEBATE.
WATCH.
>> ABRAHAM LINCOLN HERE IS ONE
OF THE MOST RACIST PRESIDENTS WE
HAVE HAD AN MODERN HISTORY.
HE POURS FUEL ON EVERY SINGLE
RACIST FIRE.
EVERY SINGLE ONE.
HE HAS MOVED AROUND AND MADE
EVERYTHING WORSE, ACROSS THE
BOARD.
THIS GUY IS A DOG WHISTLE ABOUT
AS BIG AS A FARM HORN.
>> Laura: DUKE, IT’S NOT JUST
BUY CLAIMING THAT THE PRESIDENT
IS RACIST, BUT ATHLETES,
CELEBRITIES, LOBBING THOSE
CHARGES ROUTINELY.
DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
A RACIST?
>> FOR ONE, I NEVER MET
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN MY LIFE, BUT
WHAT I CAN SAY IS I KNOW
MISS ALICE MARIE JOHNSON.
HERSCHEL WALKER WAS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE FOOTBALL PLAYERS, AND I
THINK THEY GOT TOO HIGH IN
INTEGRITY AND DIGNITY TO HANG
OUT WITH A RACIST, AND WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID FOR ME, A
BLACK MAN, I CAN’T SAY HE IS A
RACIST COME ON MY BELIEF.
NOW, WHAT OTHER PEOPLE SAY,
THEY’VE GOT THEIR OWN OPINION,
BUT WHAT HE DONE FOR ME AND, I
SAID, THE SECOND BEST THING TO
GETTING YOUR SALVATION BY
JESUS CHRIST, AND IF YOU ARE A
BELIEVER IN GOD, YOU WILL
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS AND
HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS FOR ME,
THAT THE SECOND BEST GIFT HE
GAVE ME, SO I CAN NEVER SAY THAT
HE IS A RACIST, AND THAT IS
WHERE I STAND, IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION.
>> Laura: DUKE, I’VE GOT TO
SAY, SECOND CHANCES -- WHO AMONG
US HASN’T NEEDED A SECOND
CHANCE?
AND I THINK YOUR WITNESS, JUST
YOUR PERSONAL STORY IS REALLY
MOVING.
BEYOND POLITICS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.
WE JUST REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMING ON, AND WE WISH YOU THE
BEST OF LUCK TO YOUR FAMILY, AND
THANKS FOR JOINING US TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THINK EVERYBODY IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHO HAD SOMETHING
TO DO WITH MY FREEDOM, WITH
SENDING ME BACK TO MY BOY.
TO SHOW TRUE REDEMPTION, THAT’S
WHAT I WILL DO, MAKE YOU ALL
PROUD.